I'm thrilled to be able to call this man
a friend he is one of the best in the
business
and the NFL and CBS sports are bringing
classic NFL on CBS games to CBS and CBS
Sports Network leading up to the draft
next week and I'm sure we'll be hearing
a lot of this man's voice whoo we also
heard this past weekend for a lot of the
replays of great masters moments he is
none other than Jim Nance how are you
Jim hello friend and it's great to be
with you rich I'm I'm getting excited
about some of the programming that's
coming up there with the NFL Draft and
these NFL rewinds and everybody again
under the circumstances we're doing just
fine out here in our home in California
but it's great to have a chance to visit
with you right back at you Jim and I'll
tell you what man I missed your voice
this is normally the time I mean late
March early April we're hearing you talk
about Nets being cut down we're hearing
you talk about jackets getting slipped
on
I wonder what what you've been missing
personally Jim yeah you know it's one of
those things you're constantly trying to
balance about where you are in the
present with your mind naturally
wandering off to where you're supposed
to be so it's this constant Time Warp
that is challenging for me constant
reminders from people that hey you know
today you were supposed to call the
national championship game today they
were supposed to hit the opening tee
shot at the Masters you would have been
there boy do I miss and of course I do
but you know those aren't my greatest
concerns right now
as we've had over a month to get
accustomed to this new way of life I've
just been grateful but I've had my
family here and how all three of my kids
with me for over a month my in-laws are
here and we're safe and sheltering and
we like everyone else we can't wait to
get things somewhat back to normal
eventually completely back to normal and
you know it's yeah I missed these
sporting events but I want that to be
put in the proper perspective no doubt
where we are in the world and the people
that have rallied as Americans always do
the
you know the front liners in this case
the healthcare workers and everybody
else who has really given not only their
time but put their lives on the line to
come in to try to help others itself
it's another great story of America
coming together at a time of need and
uniting as one no question and obviously
people who work on supply chains and
supply lines and being out delivering
packages or driving a bus or things that
we take for granted so much and that
obviously includes sports and and when
when we get back to sports might
actually help make everybody feel normal
and in the meantime we we hit the rewind
button as you point out like this past
weekend for the Masters did you catch
any of the the oldest of old schools of
your broadcasts from back in the day did
you catch any of those Jim I did and
every time one of them would come on
ESPN
and Golf Channel both were replaying old
masters telecasts and I'm now on old
guys been around for long so many of
them and what a blessing has been to
have 34 masters broadcasts in the bank
but as they were replaying the likes of
1986 and Jack Nicklaus is historic six
green jacket
I was flooded with people remarking that
either they didn't know that I was dated
back that far or man you look so young
meaning you look really old now but yes
I caught I caught the 86 rebroadcast of
course the 97 win for the ages by Tiger
I had never watched that again no way
rich so I never seen the rebroadcast
I've seen the quick when he puts that at
18 or a thousand times over but I had
never watched the broadcast so I and I
enjoyed getting lost in that for a few
hours hey Jim I get you instead of the
you look older like what happened your
hair I get a lot of that and I'm
stealing myself for the last dance
documentary on Jordan that ESPN is gonna
no doubt have maybe some of my
SportsCenter highlights from that last
dance season I'm I'm getting ready
stealing myself for those
texts and calls from people no you take
those as a badge of honor though that
you were there yes your career spanned
that kind of history at least that's the
way I look at it I mean I'm I still
can't believe it almost when I looked at
the 86 masters rebroadcast I was 26
years old at that time and Frank Turk
any and the legendary late producer
director for CBS they regarded as the
founder of golf television the fact that
he entrusted me to be on his broadcast
like I'm 60 now and I don't get it I
don't know what he saw I'm being serious
here how in the world do you take a guy
that's not even four years graduated
from college and put him on the 70th
hole of the biggest awful bed in the
world I mean I I I can't explain it
yeah I was nervous that day but I was
like almost more nervous watching it at
the age of 62 here you know what might
be leaving my lips back down I wasn't
for sure what I had said other than the
bear has come out of hibernation and I
remembered after I said that after
Nicholas's pivotal putt on Sunday that I
was instantly just overcome with with a
lot of doubt and regret
I thought someone else had already said
it my broadcast by the time you got the
16 there have already been announcer
announcers position from the tenth hole
on there's been a lot of commentaries
but a lot of things said so as soon as I
said it I thought why did you just
repeat something that has already been
uttered on this broadcast just beating
myself up a little bit a little bit
after the broadcast I went over to
apologize to Frank to mr. trick in Ian I
was just trying to get back for the 87th
back and I went over to a hat in hand
and said I'm so sorry Frank that a
relaunch 'red the the line of monkey
bear has come out of hibernation he said
you know he had a big presence about him
even though he was a little little short
guy who's like five five with a booming
and he said son no one said it other
than you so you're gonna be doing this
next year you might be doing this for a
while that's something a lot of my
office's shot off with some are all in a
in the tower I mean what was your
relationship with him Jim was as Allegra
strong with with Pat in fact I'm so glad
you brought up Pat is the way my mind
works I I had no idea we're gonna
mention Pat right Pat passed away but
I'll be thinking of him tomorrow when I
wake up and I look at the calendar that
it's April 16th he died he died seven
years ago tomorrow yeah he he died April
16 2013 I worked 10 years with that
obviously he was in the 18th power for
that 86 masters and I would go on and
work golf as a regular member of Frank's
broadcast team and so I worked in eighty
six seven eight nine
90 91 92 93 with with Pat he did the 94
masters and the West Coast Swing
so what's that maybe eight nine full
years of say 18 to 20 golf tournaments a
year and that's a lot of time not just
on the air but even better being able to
go out to dinner with Frank and Pat and
Ken Venturi and that whole crew that I'd
grown up watching as a kid and now
they're my colleagues I'll tell you one
quick story I was to call him on the air
mr. summer all I was just that's just
the way I was raised I was a yes or no
sir
the mr. missus you know I didn't want to
have the arrogance and thinking I could
actually talk to him like we're equals
because I wasn't and I'm still not and
so III originally was talking about my
first year on the air
I just need jerk reaction with saying
let's go back to 18 mr. Summerall and
finally Frank called me in the office
one day and to get just rip me and said
you gotta quit calling him mr. summer
all your men
it's all sound like a bunch of old fools
it's pat and yeah I took that's yes sir
mr. Kinney and I got that but but but
that was so kind generous and of course
after he left CBS to go to Fox to go
there with John Madden he still in so
many ways was a member of the CBS family
I'm not taking anything away from some
great years he had at Fox but he was a
CBS guy sure and he would he would be
around then once he retired he was
around when we would have the occasion
to go into Dallas let's say for the
Byron Nelson golf tournament
you know we had occasions where we would
get together for dinner and and a lot of
times these four dinners - let's pay
tribute to Pat let's get our entire crew
all the production and technical team
members and and yeah I just love Pat
Summerall
my gosh I mean can you I still can't
believe but I got to just sit across
from them at a table on dozens and
dozens if not hundreds of occasions and
just listen to him tell a story or
listen to him the quarter is dinner you
know was only that good start with a
salad and steak medium rare those pauses
it's really kind of I just gave you a
spin off of a story that Pat used to say
about ray Scott of course I know you and
maybe a good portion of our audience
knows that ray Scott was one of the
legendary voices of the NFL back in the
early days in the packer days and star
Dowler touchdown Green Bay well Pat
worked as an analyst next to race God so
listen Pat was naturally inclined to
speak the way that we knew him on the
air but I think there was such a heavy
influence of working alongside ray Scott
with an economy of words in a minimalist
approach to description for a visual
medium and he would talk about ray Scott
ordering breakfast bacon
over you that was God love him yeah
exactly in his wife Cherie keeping his
spirit alive with the Pat Summerall
dinner every single hey when you're a
civilian artist does and cherry does
with the Pat Summerall award with other
things for st. Jude's and you have been
my gosh god bless you rich for what
you've done for for that cause and Tibet
that that dinner every year at the Super
Bowl is amazing it's a it's an amazing
amazing of that yep we've got Tony Dungy
on and our final hour he's won the the
Summerall award every year I'm honored
to have taken that home I've seen you at
tons of them and this folks at CBS that
supported Ken a garden so many people
that support that still it's just it is
just remarkable I was lucky enough to be
the honoree one of the years ever Super
Bowl was in Phoenix you too we weren't
broadcasting at that year but we were
broadcasting the Phoenix golf tournament
on that same weekend so anyway it's
amazing it was like one of those dishes
your life moments and I mean I looked at
in the audience and you know I saw
everybody from my roommates in college
they flew in I mean you know all my
family was there Andy Rooney was there
from 60 minutes I mean it was it was
like crazy NFL distinguished alum
distinguished legendary names that were
they again they're out of respect for
Pat Summerall primarily it was just
awesome
Jim Nantz here on the Rich Eisen show
and again there's gonna be some great
games to a day on either CBS Sports Net
or CBS starting again on Thursday
starting on Thursday with a couple of
games that I think Ravens fans won't
want to revisit but the Chiefs and the
Browns will you've called so many of
them I do want to however call attention
to the Patriots right now though because
the conversation that we heard
interestingly enough I didn't think I'd
bring up a Howard Stern interview to you
Jim Nantz but that's where Tom Brady
spoke for too
hours+ last week saying that he thought
that when asked by Howard when he was
thinking that he wouldn't return in New
England he pegged a date of last summer
did you get any indication when you and
Tony would speak with him and or Bella
checked that something was not the same
in the same saying 19 hears that you had
those visits with him and Bill I really
really didn't but we all knew that he
had contractually put it in there the
clause where he was going to be able to
have his pure freedom when the season
was up so there all season long there
was that heavy speculation but did I get
tipped off or I get any sense that he
had it and said that he was gonna make a
move at the end of the year no not at
all
and that includes even you're not having
a chance to call his last game in the
patriot uniform the playoff game against
against Tennessee in the wild-card round
but no I didn't I didn't get that sense
I think it's gonna be really interesting
we usually talk on this night I can't
wait are certain things that right now
you look forward through that sports
side of our lives and that's why people
are listening to you right now and every
day you're certain things that keep us
interesting get us fired up the draft
obviously but I told you a number of
years guesting on that very night the
night of the scheduled release is one of
my favorite sporting events of the year
I love it it's like the bracket release
for the NCAA tournament yes I there's
some mystery to it the reveal I'm into
it and maybe it's because it it's just
something I did it sets course on where
my life might be going and sure certain
places and this is what we're gonna
travel to but I love to see the
disbursement of the games to all the
networks and see how that plays out but
this year my gosh
what what what Howard Katz and is in and
Cathy young and that great team that
they have to sit there and come up with
all these different models and I'm just
talking about under that the heading of
that the season goes as scheduled yep it
will be interest
to see how they delegate the games in
terms of how high-profile do you put the
Patriots the Patriots have a road
schedule this year I don't have it in
front of me but I do know they've got
Baltimore Houston and Kansas City on
their schedule I know they play at the
Chargers I know there's another game
they play on the west coast it's like
there's just a there's as Rangers it's
just it's better than better the most
daily play they play at the Raiders and
you start thinking okay do they put them
in for let's say primetime spots that
they put them in addition as the primary
for 25 game on four or five occasions
how do they see that how do they it's
more like haughtily handicap it because
that's kind of what it is isn't it rich
I mean weren't they kind of handicapping
who they think the marquee teams of
course and you've got what it course and
then you've got obviously the Chiefs
visiting Tampa so you'd have you'd have
the the repeat of obviously so many
great games of Brady and mahomes and
then this year we're knocking on
whatever this is would lose sight before
I let you go Jim that the NFL season
will go off and we will see the Masters
in November just so just to repeat your
plan would be to do the Masters that
weekend in November at Augusta and and
figure out the rest
that would be your plan you know I don't
know how they're gonna do it my thing
I'm I'm really looking forward to is
just seeing how high profile is Tampa
what what do they do with New England
you know we're the AFC Network what what
are the teams everybody's gonna want
mahomes as many times as they can get
them you're right our crossover games
over here on the AFC side talking about
the Box Kansas City and the Chargers
play a Tampa do we get both of those
games do we put them in a doubleheader
window or there's a leak put them in a
double header window this is all just
you know try to figure out how it's
going to be handicapped and it's just an
excitement for me that's building up to
that release date whenever that is I
know it's probably within a month right
yep before well the idea that maybe
sometime in May
when we might have any idea of of
scheduling and stuff like that and like
I said I can't believe that a masters
could be held in November in Augusta
that would be remarkable if that could
well go off as planned
if it happens that means that the world
is in a much better place correct you
know there are other events that are
being squeezed into that real estate
talking about the autumn month is going
to be for those who make their living
and programming and if you're a sports
fan let's look at it through the lens of
a sports fan just think of all the
things that going to happen at the
confluence of you mentioned it
the Masters how about you know the US
Open you know there's a Ryder Cup so
there's that sport all of those would be
in the autumn months with the Masters
being last up in in in in November but
you've got Grand Slam tennis events
you've got hopefully baseball playing
you know of course we've got college
football in the NFL it's just all of
these things coming together to get to
get a date down for 2020 and is let's
just hope that's that's the biggest
concern we have that the worlds in a far
better place were more centered the
world is back on its axis sports are
back competing people have that
diversion that distraction that form of
escapism in their lives and but more
than anything let's just hope
everybody's healthy and and we're able
to get people back working and their
lives are healthy and happy and and back
to the way we used to know it here here
Jim Nantz thanks to the call I really
could chat with you all the rest of this
show but you know I got Tony Dungy and
you we can't keep trying I love me too
me too for my best and I love you thank
you rich right back at you love you too
Jim Nantz you the man best in you and
your family ups Jim Nantz CBS Sports
I honestly one of the greatest
storytellers there is oh my gosh
I loved I loved my chance with him on
the show just great hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here